raus verschwinde lasst mich last lasst
mich ich ziehe jetzt bei conny ein leute
wissen doch wieder zurück um ihr projekt
nicht von uns sondern gespielt und der
congo after unter mein name ist bediener
und ja da flog mal wieder massig der
hate umher in den letzten folgen und die
man hat mich rausgeworfen seinem haus
voller angst und ein haus hat völlig
verständlich deswegen packt jetzt auch
meine sachen und gehe bitte verschwinde
ich wünsche lena ich will hier nicht
mehr sehen
ggg ja schon kannst du mit jetpack
kräften du kriegst gar nichts mehr ich
hatte auf meiner kiste städten als auf
meinem grundstück steht eine kiste von
frank i want peace ach das ist dass
janet von servonic mit übrigens sachen
geschenkt hey was du hast keine rüstung
des stücks das weißt du du stirbst ich
nicht aber wir haben hier versammelt um
über etwas zu reden da ist ja extrem gut
in unser balkon rein raus verschiedene
lass mich last lasst mich ich ziehe
jetzt bei conny 1
ihr habt in meine kuppe danke conny ja
zielgruppe möchte auch was sagen damit
ein maurer jetzt hier versammelt heute
um mich heute hier versammelt um über
sachen zu sprechen die uns stören am
projekt und ich möchte jetzt gerne mal
was sagen ihr könnt ihr könnt euch jetzt
alles sagen hier mit dies und jenes
aber soll ich mal sagen was mich richtig
stört penisse in der stadt
die stören mich halt der verfügtes mal
etwas mache ich auch einsperren
allerdings auf dich drauf magst du keine
penisse ich komme es zu euch kommen
also ich hab mal als oben bei mir macht
ihr da schon da natürlich ich habe so
ein schönes bauhausjahr naja hab mir
viel mühe gegeben mit der gestaltung
eines gesprengt habe ich wieder
aufgebaut habe viel mühe geben alles so
alle anderen kommen oder spark oder das
altes haus oder solartechnik in seinen
in seinen eigenen haus immer hatte hatte
jemand versucht ein schönes haus zu
machen sogar zornig
und und riol alle haben versucht ein
schönes auszubauen und roter riese pilz
und was macht conny er baut nennt ps
alter ich hatte auch ein schönes land
wolle ich mich auf technik konzentrieren
jetzt habe ich mir gedacht ja gut kann
ich auch mal eigentlich jetzt unserem
himmel bauen
außerdem was den aufnahme von revieren
stand und außerdem finde ich den so geil
und wie man sie bitte einmal da oben
rein und überzeugt sich von der aussicht
da was aus was für aus sicht junger dich
so nah ist was blick über alles über die
komplette welt von firma ist vielleicht
für dich was besonderes aber ich wurde
auf dem baumhaus ich hab immer so ein
ausblick zum euro aber ich habe kein
baum jetzt verpiss dich hier hast du als
nackte bist du nackt conny ja der witz
ich meine sachen aus youtube gestreift
werden wegen sexuell explizite
verwandten hier willst du nicht weißt
ich es nicht kann ich es vielleicht sein
weiß nicht ein richtiger penis ist
einfach so ein paar pixel sind aber ich
kann's auch zensieren sich zensieren ja
mal die ganze folge durch auch bei den
er einfach wegen sex- oder geilheit
roman der ist einfach nackt hat einfach
ein penis unten hängen hat hier ein
penis und wenn das auch als auch
gestreikt weil dafür aus die pläne als
fragte man sich überall penis war als
wunschdenken
tommy haas ist ich pass auf ich sag dir
was ich gerne hätte ja ich hätte gerne
ein projekt wo wir zusammen das so alles
machen wie in einem rollenspiel wowereit
gemeinsam häuser aufbauen und das alles
auch geregelt ist bei einem rollenspiels
auch alles geredet da muss man die quest
machen und so was alles was alles
geregelt wird dann auch alles geregelt
sein dass zum beispiel videos schon
gesagt hast wenn man stirbt es mann tot
wenn man den grabstein dann zum beispiel
nicht wegnimmt oder so habe ich zum
beispiel bei dir gesehen ja nie wie
viele solarpanels das team nicht so
viele arbeiten des lv oder mv weil sie
nicht gucke ich habe einen mv auch dabei
du weißt ist nicht mal chrysler steht
heute das solarpanel lassen mv und wo
sicher ist ein falls er das jetzt im
parlament in der mitte ja da wo sie
besteht im falle dieser nicht verstanden
was soll ich noch in mv anschließen
dürfen will also jeder kommt zu mir
wären allerdings ein mietvertrag gemacht
dass mit denen er soll nicht der ganze
stress kommen also soll nicht auf einmal
yuki hochgehen ich kenne kann ich mir
den ganzen mehr projekt ab jetzt keine
einzige bombe mahnerin kein eu kein tnt
kann gar nichts ok in der kompletten
zeit keine einzige nuke wäre ja keine
einzige klein und ich werde absolut gar
nichts mehr machen aber den halter wird
doch nicht mehr träumen was er jedoch
nicht gemacht hat und bei dem er macht
macht er auch was bei mir dann hat der
dena und mich gegen ihn
aha und trocken samstags ein jemand
gegen ihn und immer so weiter
naja bringt doch überhaupt nicht aber
was ich sagte ich werde auch nichts mehr
machen denn jemand ziemlich alt ist ist
mir scheißegal
auch bei einmal gesagt haben ja den er
kann ja nicht ein ich konnte machen
hallo mein ganzes haus das werk mein
ganzes hab und gut ist weg also als ob
ich hier ich habe schon mal schon mal
meine quantum alles verloren also juli
vor allem verstehe ich das nicht was die
ganzen user jetzt immer so haben von
wegen jahr den oscar der schlimme der
hier alles gemacht hat ich meine ja bei
dehner der hat sechs nukes gezählt was
natürlich heftig ist allerdings muss man
davor bedenken dass lena davor nie
geträumt hat so zum beispiel brocken
vermisst man richtig finde luft
gesprengt schaut mal gespielt
gibt sich folgen die ersten 70 folgen
ich habe sowieso nie bei ihr
eingetrudelt seien immer nur antworten
gemacht und nur wenn es wirklich schon
krass war bei mir und ich haben ihm
irgendwie so ein troll gemacht so im
sinne von world war hier wohl die miese
aktion und boah voll witzig und sowohl
ihr müsst auch mal überlegen stellt euch
mal vor ihr baut die ganze zeit 70
folgen also locker mehrere stunden
mehrere weise nicht im kompletten tag 24
stunden keine ahnung 70 folgen hat in
einem projekt an einem haus was geil
aussieht weil technik drin hat und auf
einmal ist einfach so eine druckplatte
die eine menge kaputt macht die wo simon
lagerraum aus stört was zwar nicht die
man schulter was aber irgendwer gemacht
hat und er hätte er zugegeben dann wäre
es auch nur noch ein viertel so schlimm
gewesen wenn das zugegeben hätte dann
ins gefängnis gemusst und ihm die sachen
zurückgegeben hätte aber es hat ja nicht
mal einer zu geben von daher kann ich
die reaktion von denen er verstehen weil
däne hat ja gesagt ja wenn die person
das nicht zugibt hier dann ziemlich
innerhalb der nächsten drei tage dann in
uk drei tage zeit keiner hat gesagt ihr
das war ich hab auch keine ahnung wer es
war und wissen es ja immer maria ist ja
das schlimme
märz immer noch ich zugeben ich weiß
nicht ich hab ich keine ahnung wer es
war irgendwie ist übrigens mein mv solar
zeugs weg ich habe nur noch unglaublich
of the year low voltage aber immerhin
vielleicht einen auf der insel gelassen
ja das habe ich das habe ich stimmt ja
es wurde mir die kommentare china nicht
vergessen aber ich bin der 411 immerhin
das auch schon mal und ich liebe dich
ich liebe dich auch für zwei hv herzchen
und so wartet muss mal bei broken fans
gucken ob wir überhaupt bei denen noch
die ganzen hühner der fahndung sind
naja war für mich ein traum für mich ist
nicht in troy damit einfach irgendwo
aber selbst wenn ich in folge idee von
conny dass er den einfach mal da und
geht nicht in dieses loch war da hat
sich jemand gedacht der super witzig
welches loch oder wie sie sind hier so
heftige türme in der stadt
er weiß auch guckt naja zum beispiel
sondern ich habe mir das super witzig so
was wie dann einfach mal hier der hühner
reinlegen so dass diese daran also sowas
sollte was ihr jetzt da gerade seht das
ist für mich ein troll das nicht einfach
so ganz viele hühner reporte und dass
die wiederkommen denkt sich helfer um
ist unsere farben da so warm ist es sind
also viel wiener leute lautet dann schon
wieder einmal sind die hühner
candida vielleicht auch überdenken diese
art von isabella töten die die hühner da
machen die farbe wieder mal dass es
passt aber wenn die wiederkommen würden
und ich wird ganz viele tnt bei denen
darunter setzen das hätte ich so was
nicht geil und dann werden wir es dann
auch eine bestrafung würde ich uns was
alles also das ding macht meist vor sich
hatte strato nie eingehalten haben mir
und ich hab das folge zum beispiel
gesehen bei denen das folge er geht da
rein sieht erstmals schild wo steht li
begrüßte den etwas nicht von dena ist
eine lüge ist mit bestrafung wert und
dann geht er durch das portal durch und
wird einfach instant getötet von seiner
schreibmaschine basbug ich weiß nicht ob
es dann spark oder peter oder weise
nicht aber ist mir jetzt auch egal
jedenfalls ist der das gemacht hat ich
finde das einfach nur scheiße ist es für
mich ganz toll das ist einfach dann nur
unnötig einfach nur als auch noch eine
sache ist benaglio sieht man so ein ding
hier war das so ein ding hier strafen
reden denn das immer noch wie eine
strafe gab obwohl kläger für für die
explosion über mein haus ist weg ja aber
die extreme willst jetzt dass ich dir
sozialstunden ableisten jetzt hier ich
niemals der konfi gefallen haben ja ich
finde es von 40 wenn der jetzt mal zehn
folgen lang immer sozialarbeit macht ein
genau ist das problem ist sie die sache
ist auch stellt euch mal vor renate krad
entstand weil niemand in jener strafen
bekommen und plötzlich leute wollen wir
mal einfach so jetzt in dieser folge ins
gemeinschaftshaus lassen wieder aufbauen
ist problem also das problem ist diese
sache
es gibt kein richter hier es gibt
niemand der strafbescheide derjenigen
strafe entscheiden würde der wäre denn
in den straßen scheinen würde werde der
dumme der der böse der sich als stärker
aus gips weise und ich zum beispiel hp
server und wenn etwas schiefläuft werden
universe gesprengt hat da habe ich da
habe ich dann direkt ganz viel
kommentare kommen sieht man warum hast
du das nicht warum nicht erstmalig
überhaupt nicht das recht hat das
verändern weil ich ohne also ich habe
eine stimme dann auch jeder andere und
ich persönlich muss sagen ich war
gespannt auf den er seine runde wirklich
luft sprengt hab ja sogar ein bisschen
angestachelt dazu und ich sag ich mal
war dabei als ich das gar nicht mal so
ich hätte ihn nicht aufhalten dürfen
weil ich was hätte machen sollen
ich dachte gar nicht dass gegen gewesen
so bettoni noch nicht angreifen dürfen
im stadtkern und deswegen also ich
konnte
dagegen machen und den bahn wäre hätte
ich machen dürfen es wäre einfach
gewesen
das problem ist jeder verstöße gegen
regeln keiner kann etwas dagegen machen
weil es gibt keine richtige richtung so
in diesem neuen projekt was ich plane
also in dem neuen display projektplaner
da wird es dann richtige richter geben
damit es klare regeln geben oder wird es
nicht mehr so zimperlich laufen wenn da
irgendwas gibt es am anfang anfang an
mit euch zusammen klären wir die regeln
ja also wir werden heuer am anfang so
was wie eine regel liste oder sowas will
ich gemeinsam vorliegt wird noch genau
wisst was die regeln sind könnt ihr auch
genau darauf achten können und dann das
alles wirklich sollen gesitteten ablauf
vertrag nicht dass hier dann so
entschieden wird natürlich und aber
nicht alles mit regeln festhält und ihre
ode an die freude heute kassieren muss
man dann auch einfach in den bereichen
passiert aber halt da sein damit wir uns
als erste an damit das nicht passiert
wird dann auch genau gesagt was von
strafen und für was bekommt ungefähr und
damit die leute wissen was dann passiert
und für bestimmte sachen gibts einheiten
bahn und zum beispiel ist bauen geht im
rollenspiel projekt gar nicht und ich
möchte gern sie ja ich meine nur als
beispiel oder hat auch sachen die luft
sprengen von einer leuten und so dass
wir dann so sein
das ist zwar krieg gibt zwischen drei
städten vielleicht mal es gibt so ist
und wir können die rechte zum beispiel
in frieden zusammen sein oder im krieg
oder was auch immer die grand slams
selber entscheiden aber es wird dann
bestimmte bereiche geben in dem man
sachen zerstören und bekämpfen kann so
aber es gibt auch sachen die sind im
schutzbereich wenn da was zerstört wird
gibt es eine band oder gibts sowas ja
auf jeden fall das sowieso in der festen
statt
wenn wir die grundstücke relativ klein
sein da kann man dann so verwinkelt
mittelalterlich bauen und da darf
wirklich nichts kaputt machen wird da
was kaputt macht der fliegt sofort aus
dem prado ist und alles ist so voller
ist so ist wird am anfang flächen und
jetzt sage nicht in den kommentaren höhe
dort auch selbst ist meister kaputt
gemacht wenn ich sowas lese alter denkt
immer so
das sind das für menschen ja das ist ja
was wohl ihr trainer hat jetzt immer
dieses image bekommen das hat er alles
zerstört und so weil auch dieses thema
und so lange liefen so aber muss sich
mal überlegen was denn eigentlich
gemacht hat den hat einmal mit rewe
zusammen doppel ko gemacht mit der mit
der portugal wo er bei rewe nicht
nennenswerte sachen zerstört hat und
sich selbst getötet hat weil er einfach
nur doof ist im stück brot der däne dann
und das selber das war's witzigsten ganz
noch nicht als zurückgegeben mit jupiter
dann dann wird das haus gesprengt und
den hatte irgendwann auch kein bock mehr
hat er gesagt ich springe ein großes
erweckt hatte sich wahrscheinlich um
zwei dinger verzehrt oder sohn hat ein
bisschen zu viel weg sprecher des tsv
weniger macht ist so genau dein
grundstück wahrscheinlicher aber auch
wenn zwei weniger wären nur deswegen
auch angefeuert so zusammenkommen der
macht und so war jeder wollte
wahrscheinlich sehen was ihnen unter
kantor von frei sprechen auch die leute
wollten alle sehen aber ich hab nicht
gedacht ist die stadt dabei die luft
bringt habe gedacht da springt ihr das
einen wunsch hätte die ein bisschen
ausgelacht aber wenn mein haus mein name
auch sie selber gespielt wurde ja ich
hatte ja nicht das ziel bolt macht die
stadt kaputt mein ziel war ich machen
das durch den fetten kraft wenn man ganz
grund ist einfach nur noch ein krater
sein das verstehen hat wenig das ist
dass das ziel von der grundstücks ist
das denn sonja oder irgendwie rache oder
so an wem solchen rache nehmen wenn wenn
ich nicht weiß wer das war einfach gut
niemand mehr als ich gut dann kann ich
auf meinem grundstück komplett zu
stellen wenn das wetter wenn es ihm als
darsteller gut das habe ich auch solchen
schlag sagt dena hat ja einen countdown
des blabla von drei tagen gesetzt und
sich die personen nicht meldet dann
selbst schuld sage ich mal komme hat
jetzt natürlich verpackt aber er durfte
sie am game und wiederaufbau daher
ich kann die reaktion von calyon später
aufgebaut ja ich kann die reaktion von
denen eigentlich komplett nachvollziehen
deswegen bin ich überhaupt nicht auf der
seite von den zuschauern die bei den von
geradezu zeit so rum hätten also ich bin
eigentlich immer so eine person die
eigentlich auf alle seiten so eingeht
und sich von allen seiten meinung
einholt aber jetzt bin ich wirklich
vollkommen bei der welt stellt sich vor
wenn ich zum beispiel als mein haus noch
stand und ich da wirklich dann mehrere
folgen angebaut haben dann gerade eine
technik anfang hab ich gehe hier eine
druckplatte wo ich nichts gemacht haben
alle kinder doch damit ich auch denken
[ __ ] euch alter [ __ ] euch einfach so
hab ich kein bock drauf an dem neuen
projekt wird nicht so sein dass es so
ist dass immer neue leute zu kommen
sondern es gibt eine feste gruppe am
anfang die ist drin
wer ist genau weiß weiß ich selber nicht
100 prozentig und das weiß eigentlich
noch keiner
es wird extra nicht ist wenn nicht alle
von mega projekt seien damit jedoch ist
anderes ist war jetzt mehr übrig
weiter das heißt vielleicht also maximal
die hälfte der teilnehmer auf dem
megaprojekt die da drin sind dann
nochmal eine hälfte von anderen leuten
bei ich möchte nicht die ganzen leute
mehr fragt wer ist dasselbe nur ein grün
das soll ja nicht alle losen megaprojekt
bei sein sondern auch andere leute und
dann ist soll er auf einer eventuell
dadurch nochmal neue leute kennenlernt
dass leute dann auch noch mal unser
wieder neu kennen das die agentur wieder
neue kontakte knüpfen und so was alles
und dann ja sein so dass wenn jemand
sich gegen die regeln verstößt so ist er
halt gebannt und da hat eine neue person
chance wieder reinzukommen
dann kann eine stadt die man verloren
hat man halt die chance bekommen ok und
ist jemand verloren damit spielern weil
der arzt steht daneben benommen oder so
und es ist er raus aus dem projekt
vielleicht können wir jemand neues zu
werben vielleicht hat auch mal von den
zuschauern glück ja wenn wir sehen okay
da hat sich jemand richtig bemühte als
jemand in fast in allen folgen immer gut
mit hier kommentiert bewertet was auch
immer da wo man sagt die von einfachen
bei der reise verfolgt hat auch selber
gezeigt auf seinem kanal dass der
qualitativ vielleicht da mithalten kann
wir wollen natürlich auch wieder als
aufnehmen und der deshalb wirklich ein
winzig kleiner ist auch mit flash 100
abonnenten wenn er uns bewiesen hat der
ist ein cooler typ so der ist dabei der
fiat mit und der ist auch von der
qualität her sodass man ja auch normal
menschlich entscheiden genau dann
vielleicht kommt er ja vielleicht auch
jemand anders vielleicht man weiß noch
nicht genau
ich werde überhaupt nicht festlegen es
wird auch nicht es wird überhaupt nicht
sagen
der kommt irgendwann der einst jedoch
keine warteliste so was wirst du es nie
geben sie doch keine werbung geben
es gibt eine feste gruppe von anfragen
und diese feste gruppe wird dann so
bleiben
bis jemand sich etwas zuschulden kommen
lässt und wenn jemand der ausweg ist
halt raus und wird dann halt auch streng
behandelt und dann wird halt einfach
strenge regeln geben so und ich möchte
gerne was gemeinsam ist aufbauen mit
menschen
ich möchte gerne display machen was auch
mal wirklich tiefgründiger sein kann ich
mich mal was gemeinsam aufbauen menschen
ich möchte mal was wohl nicht immer nur
kaputt gemacht wird und so und darauf
wohl nicht ständiger wettkampf herrscht
ja auch dieses auch dieser wettkampf so
das ist das ist auch so eine sache
ihr müsst euch mal überlegen viele
wissen das sei alles genau so abgelaufen
ist das wort
es war eine zeit lang megaprojekt so
dass es nur noch darum ging wer der
beste und weitest in allen sachen ist
und so ihr wisst dass ehrlicher zu
schauen das habt ihr wahrscheinlich auch
zwischendurch einfach keine lust mehr
hatte irgendwie eine phase erreicht
wurde das ist nur darum gehen wir haben
weitesten war oder damals und wollte und
deswegen also ich hatte auch eine
zeitlang gesagt ich hab keine lust auf
technik ich schreibe einfach ein buch
ein buch braucht darum ging auf jetzt
den technik- oder so bin
es gab ja leute die haben dann keine
ahnung einfach nur versucht damit ist
dieses es gibt viele sachen die da unten
rum passiert dieses team work oder auch
so was was einfach das projekt sollte
anfangszeiten teamprojekt sein wo
einfach jeder gemeinsam was macht und da
ist wirklich schade dass da das ist so
viele leute dann irgendwie nur versucht
haben irgendwie einfach nur diese ego
diego masche durchziehen und das ist
keine ahnung den er weiß was mir
auffällt man so ganz nebenbei kurz als
ich dabei dir auf deine new getreten bin
habe ich beide diamant spitzhacken von
mir verloren beide waren verzaubert
dieser reifen oder bist du gestorben ja
ich bin gestorben radiation oa hessen
nicht wieder gefunden
fällt mit einer sechs millimeter haben
kann ich mir doch aus diamanten ja ich
kann mir daraus keine level machen
ich habe auch noch irgendwann merke ich
glaube dadurch entstanden und kann es
jetzt weitergehen na ja auf jeden fall
ich arbeite daran mal gucken wer so
dabei sein wird weiß er noch nicht genau
auf jeden fall ja also es soll auf jeden
fall besser geregelt werden damit in
sachen nicht passieren können allerdings
es werden auf jeden fall am anfang
heftige regeln gemacht werden was heißt
heftige regen auf jeden fall eine menge
regeln so dass alles geregelt ist damit
keine ausbrechen die passieren kann
andererseits achten wir darauf dass wir
leute haben die solche ausbrecher gar
nicht zulassen
und wenn trotzdem was passiert was nicht
in den regeln steht dann haben wir immer
noch leute die wie simon meinte vor ein
paar folgen
ja da gibt es dann verschiedene städte
oder sowas dass die dann individuell
entscheiden über strafen oder was so
geschehen werden soll also dass das
ganze an sich so besser geplant ist von
grund auf sage ich mal gespannt wie es
wird
und ja das waren doch jetzt ungefähr so
20 minuten fast die wieder aufgenommen
haben scheißegal was mit dem thema ich
finde kann ich weiß einer von euch ganz
kurz wie man aus der ju meter diamanten
macht alles voll machen aber ein
verbessertes wenn du erst gold macht und
das dann mit dem minimum stone
umwandelten
ja also ich würde sagen es wird startet
das was damit in folge wenn es euch
gefallen hat und ja auch eigentlich
irgendwie so denkt jahre müsste es hier
mal ein paar sachen muss man eventuell
irgendwann irgendwer jetzt ein einsicht
bekommen hat dass das mit denen
eigentlich gar nicht den schuldner
sondern eigentlich die von den anderen
mehr oder weniger beziehungsweise den us
meinung verständlich ist dann sagt das
einfach